- ♪ O CANADA
♪ OUR HOME AND NATIVE LAND
♪ TRUE PATRIOT LOVE
♪ IN ALL THY SONS COMMAND
- LOOKS LIKE THE ZAMBONI
MISSED SOME CARPET.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE THINKING.
THAT WOULD MAKE A GREAT
WEB REDEMPTION.
AND APPARENTLY, YOU'RE NOT
THE ONLY ONE WHO THOUGHT SO.
LISTEN, I'M AWARE
AMERICA'S FUNNIEST HOME VIDEOS
AND TALK SOUP HAVE
A LEGITIMATE GRIPE AGAINST ME.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH MTV HAS
A PG GIRL VERSION OF THIS SHOW.
BUT NOW SPORTS CHANNELS
ARE STEALING FROM ME?
DID ESPN REALLY THINK
I WOULDN'T NOTICE
WHEN THEY CAME UP
WITH AN EERILY FAMILIAR
NEW SEGMENT CALLED
"AWESOME VIDEO SEGMENT"?
- WE GOT A NEW DEVICE
COMING UP.
IT'S CALLED--
THE INAUGURAL PIECE IS CALLED
THE AWESOME VIDEO SEGMENT,
AND THIS ONE CENTERS
ON THAT--THAT SKATING,
TRIPPING-OVER-THE-RED-CARPET
SINGER GUY WHOSE NAME--
HE'S GOT A NAME--
IS MARK DONNELLY.
- ♪ LAND
- YOU'VE SEEN IT ON
SPORTSCENTER A MILLION TIMES,
BUT IF YOU'RE LIKE ME,
YOU STILL HAVE
A MILLION QUESTIONS.
I WENT TO CANADA
AND ASKED MARK DONNELLY
WHAT HE WAS THINKING.
- I DON'T KNOW WHY
I DIDN'T NOTICE THE--
WHEN I WENT AROUND BEFORE,
AND THEN WITH
THE TWO SPOTLIGHTS ON ME,
I COULDN'T SEE
WHAT WAS IN FRONT OF ME.
- ALL RIGHT, LISTEN CLOSELY
AND TELL ME
IF YOU'VE HEARD
THIS NEXT PHRASE BEFORE.
- DO YOU THINK
YOU WOULD BE WILLING
TO GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT?
- THEY MUST HAVE MISSED
THAT ONE EPISODE
WHERE I SAID THAT BEFORE.
ARE YOU READY TO GIVE IT
ANOTHER SHOT?
ARE YOU READY
TO GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT?
YOU READY TO GIVE IT
ANOTHER SHOT?
ARE YOU READY TO GIVE IT
ARE YOU READY
TO GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT?
- DO YOU THINK
YOU WOULD BE WILLING
TO GIVE IT ANOTHER SHOT?
- SURE.
♪ O CANADA
♪ OUR HOME AND
[triumphant music]
♪ O CANADA
♪ WE STAND ON GUARD
♪ FOR THEE
[cheers and applause]
- YOU [bleep] HACKS
ARE CHEAPENING MY BRAND.
I'M FINE WITH KIDS
IN HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE
PLAGIARIZING,
BUT ONCE YOU WORK
FOR A REAL NETWORK,
YOU SHOULD HAVE
SOME GODDAMN SELF-RESPECT.
THAT'S WHY I CREATED
A NEW SEGMENT
CALLED SPORTSCIENCE.0.
WHO DO YOU THINK CAME UP
WITH THAT--
A NETWORK DEDICATED TO SPORTS
OR BILL NYE'S SON,
THE SPORTS SCIENCE GUY?
THEY'VE BEEN CALLING ME THAT
SINCE I WAS [bleep] 11.
[dramatic music]
ON ESPN'S FLAGSHIP SHOW
SPORTSCENTER,
EACH HIGHLIGHT LASTS AN AVERAGE
OF 45 SECONDS
AND CONTAINS AN ASTONISHING
217 UNFUNNY FORCED PUNS.
AND THE [...] FRAT BROTHERS
THEY CALL ANCHORS
ARE WHIFFING ON AN IMPROBABLE
100% OF THE JOKES
THEY TRY TO MAKE.
THAT'S LIKE A GREASED UP
ADULT GRIZZLY BEAR
TRYING TO MAKE LOVE
TO A FRESH SALMON.
THAT'S LIKE--
SPORTSCENTER BREAKS DOWN
LIKE THIS:
60% MANZIEL GOSSIP,
39% PRAISING LEBRON
FOR BUYING A GIANT BRITA FILTER
TO CLEAN LAKE ERIE,
72% JERKING OFF THE S.E.C.,
AND 41% EXPLAINING AWAY
WHATEVER CRIME AN NFL PLAYER
COMMITTED THAT HOUR.
THERE'S 2% OTHER,
WHICH IS ROOM
FOR WHOMEVER HAS TO FILL IN
FOR BILL SIMMONS
EVERY TIME HE'S SUSPENDED
FOR HAVING THE AUDACITY
TO DEFEND WOMEN.
ESPN'S 72 PERSONALITIES
WHO HAVE NO PERSONALITY
CAN SOMEHOW MANAGE
TO EXERT ENOUGH FORCE
TO CLIMB ALL THE WAY
INTO THE NFL'S ASSHOLE.
FORMER ATHLETES ACCOUNT
FOR ALMOST 1/3
OF ESPN PERSONALITIES,
AND WITH A GRAMMATICAL ERROR
EVERY FIFTH WORD,
A NORMAL SEGMENT CONTAINS
NEARLY 400 INSTANCES
OF FLAWED SYNTAX.
SIMPLE MATHEMATICS TELLS US
THAT IS A STATISTICAL ANOMALY.
CHRIS BERMAN'S
WEEKLY 2-MINUTE DRILL
RUNS AN AVERAGE
OF 5 MINUTES AND 11 SECONDS.
THAT'S 5 MINUTES AND 11 SECONDS
MORE
THAN ANYONE OUTSIDE OF BUFFALO
WANTS TO HEAR CHRIS BERMAN
GARGLE
ON ALL SEVEN OF HIS CHINS.
AND THAT PAINFULLY UNAWARE
PUDGY OLD MAN
MAKES $3 MILLION A YEAR.
THAT'S MORE THAN ALL-PROS
ANDREW LUCK AND JULIO JONES.
SCIENCE!
FOR A MEASLY $5.64 BILLION,
ESPN WON
THE BROADCASTING RIGHTS
TO THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL PLAYOFFS
FOR THE NEXT 12 YEARS.
ZERO DOLLARS OF THAT WILL GO
TO THE ATHLETES.
ESPN PROFITS
OFF KIDS PLAYING FOOTBALL,
WHICH MEANS THEY SUPPORT KIDS
GETTING BRAIN DAMAGE,
WHICH MEANS ESPN
WANTS CHILDREN TO DIE,
OR TO PUT IT
IN SCIENTIFIC TERMS,
ESPN LOVES KILLING KIDS.
SCIENCE.
FOR SPORTSCIENCE.0,
I'M DANIEL TOSH.
FOR THE RECORD,
THAT WAS NOT AIMED
AT MIKE AND MIKE, SIMMONS,
BEADLE, PTI, LE BATARD.
YOU GUYS ARE COOL.